an ngo claims china is using kidnapping
and coercion as tools to bring wanted
fugitives abroad back to the country all
this in violation of international law
today the ngo safeguard defenders
released its latest report involuntary
returns china's covert operation to
force fugitives back home
now the communist party calls these
repatriations voluntary returns but
safeguard defenders argues they are
anything but such is the case of china's
one-time most wanted corruption suspect
yang shuju
now this is her in 2016 being escorted
off a plane upon her court return to
beijing a former communist party
official accused of embezzlement she
arrived from the united states where she
had been in hiding safeguard defenders
claims her family members had been
threatened in china forcing yang to
return the ngo claims there are three
main methods that china uses to coerce
overseas targets to return
first of all as in young's case pressure
on the targets family in china that
ranges from threats to harassment and
public shaming to actual detention of
family members if that doesn't work
china will dispatch agents to whatever
country the target happens to be in to
use more direct methods of persuasion
that can include intensive surveillance
and stalking and if those means are
exhausted the report documents case
studies of covert teams actually
kidnapping and smuggling people back to
china
it's all part of china's so-called fox
hunt and skynet programs that seek to
bring back fugitives from abroad and cut
their access to finances but as the
report from safeguard defenders says
china's actions violate international
law
the ngo's campaign director laura harth
explained how that was the case
as you pointed out uh china i mean the
ccp is breaking international law
national sovereignty of at least 120
countries as their official statements
uh point out uh on a regular basis what
we've documented in this report is that
the campaigns that have started in 2014
uh reinforced in 2015 and again in 2018
um foxhunt and then skynet the so-called
anti-corruption campaign where
anti-corruption is to be taken very
broadly uh basically hunting chasing uh
dissidents
activists uh a growing number of people
trying to flee china as official numbers
indicate uh everywhere in the world now
instead of using official legal
mechanisms which obviously we've
documented they're increasingly trying
to do abusing the interpol system trying
to have people extradited or deported
however the majority of of people and
and we're talking over 10 000 people
that have been returned since operation
foxhound started in 2014
according to official data by the
chinese government
the majority of these people are
returned to so-called irregular means
now the irregular means again are
documented in official statements by the
chinese government by official party and
state organs um and these we call them
involuntary returns uh where they
operate on foreign soil where they
harass people on foreign soil people
that are protected and coerce them or
even kidnap them
and trap them to make sure they return
to china to be prosecuted to be
disappeared
you talked about
illegal means i mean china has something
like 60 extradition agreements almost 60
extradition agreements with different
countries
why is this not a viable
legal route for china
so one thing is they state that they use
this irregular means is illegal means
for countries where you know extradition
may be difficult where there may be no
willingness to sign extradition treaties
to sign judicial corporation treaties
now first of all this is a lie because
the you know over 30 of the cases that
we've documented and these are only the
tip of the iceberg have taken place in
countries where such agreements are in
place but obviously because of the
judicial system within china uh they're
facing increasing difficulties to have
people extradited because you know
there's been mass accounts and also by
u.n bodies clearly stating of the
torture going on arbitrary detention and
false disappearances the certainty of an
unfair trial if extradited to china so
increasingly they're facing these
difficulties so obviously it's much
easier to actually harass threaten or
even outright take people and bring them
back to china through these irregular
means
you talked about about 120 countries
where such
illegal operations are taking place my
question is are countries not aware of
these extrajudicial means that china is
employing i mean for instance how are
chinese agents able to operate under the
radar like this on foreign soil
so one of the things that we clearly ask
governments to do is to urgently
investigate and expose these practices
because in a lot of cases we do think
countries are not necessarily aware of
these um operations taking place
obviously one of the side goals of these
kind of operations is also to curse
people into silence to make sure that
they do not report this kind of
instances um this is all done also to
instill a sense of fear in the community
that they are not safe anywhere that
they're not free to speak up anywhere
that their
family back in china may be targeted
that they may be visited
by thugs by police officers abroad that
they might be kidnapped so that's one
effect which makes it obviously
difficult to monitor these practices and
to provide adequate protection
for these people but in other countries
we've seen that they have become aware
and are maybe not necessarily
investigating uh enough
other countries still especially
authoritarian states partner countries
to china may even have been cooperating
willfully with uh chinese law
enforcement to actually conduct these
kind of illegal operations irregular
operations um you know with their silent
uh complicity so there's a big a big
problem going on um and as you said they
might be using you know police officers
might be using uh tourist visas in 2020
we exposed such an agreement with
switzerland where actually police
officers were granted sometimes tourist
visas by the swiss authorities and they
might have conducted these kind of
operations other countries like italy
from where i'm speaking of has this kind
of uh agreements with chinese police
enforcement agencies
for so-called you know tourist purposes
where they may come and patrol and help
control the chinese population so
there's various degrees of cooperation
complicity and unawareness but this
needs to stop now because you know it's
a threat to national sovereignty to
human rights to freedoms everywhere
briefly uh laura what should countries
be doing to stop these illegal
activities
so the first thing is exactly to
investigate and to expose these
practices for too long and still we see
many countries adopting a kind of
hush-hush approach to the continuous
violations of international law in this
aspect but also in other aspects by the
ccp uh by prc authorities so the first
one is to really look into this again
this is linked to also their obligations
of each country of these 120 countries
targeted under international treaties to
protect and defend human rights on their
soil so they need to install adequate
monitoring
mechanisms reporting mechanisms for
these communities and make sure they are
protected investigate exposed
also you know put a price on these kind
of violations as i said i mean many of
these operations are being carried out
in countries that have judicial
cooperation agreements or extradition
treaties with china these need to be
suspended these need to be um
looked at what is happening why is this
happening there needs to be a prize on
these kind of violations of national
sovereignty and human rights everywhere
obviously we hope especially members of
parliament may take this up as a matter
of urgency with their governments and
make sure these practices are exposed
talked about
laura hart from safeguard defenders
there now beijing's repressive tactics
extend not just to transnational justice
but also press freedoms and nowhere has
that been more visible than in hong kong
in recent months well-known media
outlets such as apple daily stand news
and citizen news have had no choice but
to shut shop it's prompted several
journalists to abandon hong kong for
safety abroad dw's joyce lee meets some
in democratic taiwan
just two months ago allen still had hope
for his future as a journalist he
brought his press cards with him when he
moved from hong kong to taipei but they
are now worthless after the hong kong
news outlets he worked for shut down
amid pressure from beijing
[Music]
i've been a reporter for six years
all the news outlets i've worked for are
gone one after the other it feels like
my identity is fading away too
this is the third time alan which is not
his real name lost his job in just six
months he was an investigative reporter
for apple daily but the police detained
several editors and the paper closed
i used to work closely with the people
arrested it's terrifying and the threat
feels so imminent at first i thought
things would get better after a while
but then you heard of former colleagues
being brought to the police station and
going missing
it's like they're clearing frontline
journalists
pro-democracy publications like apple
daily stan news and citizen news went
dark after enormous government pressure
authorities have insisted that press
freedom remains protected a recent
survey by the hong kong foreign
correspondents club found otherwise more
than 70 percent of the journalists said
they were worried about being arrested
or prosecuted for the work under the
national security law
nearly half the respondents were
considering leaving the city
chang chihuahua fled to taiwan six
months ago shortly after he was sacked
by the public broadcaster aoji hk he
hosted a popular satirical show which is
why the authorities targeted him
before i left i was counting down my
days
when is it my turn to be charged
but no one has the answer
not yourself not your editor-in-chief
not the police
it's stressful to live with such
uncertainty
ho now has his own youtube channel he
posts clips and comments on hong kong's
current affairs
i now have the freedom that people in
hong kong don't have
i feel obliged to speak out for them
i still collaborate with people in hong
kong and i must consider their safety
under the security law that's their
unfortunate fate
ellen says his first priority is his
mental health after all the trauma but
he plans to keep reporting the stories
of overseas hong kongers
being a journalist is more than just a
job title
it's also a way of life to seek the
truth to think critically and to care
for the underprivileged
we can see things through these lenses
and continue reporting even without our
job titles
but it will be a struggle for alan to
build a readership without resources
it's a fate shared by many of his fellow
journalists back in hong kong only they
haven't gotten out yet